Prime Minister Teresa May has lowered
Britain's terror threat level from
critical to severe this after British
police made two more arrests in
connection with the deadly bombing
attack at the Manchester Arena 22 people
were killed and dozens left injured
after attending an ariana grande concert
there Monday night Isis has claimed
responsibility for the attack
Jonathan Vigliotti is in Manchester this
morning with the latest Jonathan good
morning
good morning Alex we're here in CNN
Square where you can see this growing
memorial thousands of flowers and
balloons in honor of all the victims
there's also hundreds of armed police
out on the street as you mentioned that
critical level has been reduced to
severe which means that this
investigation is starting to take
further shape police overnight raided
another home in Manchester and arrested
two men as British authorities said
they've rounded up the majority of the
arena bombers known associates
counter-terror chief mark Rowley they're
very significant these arrests we're
very happy we've got our hands around
some of the key players that we're
concerned about they'll say there's
still a little bit more to do searches
are still taking place at a handful of
locations around the city of the people
arrested all of them are men between the
ages of 18 and 38 as this investigation
continues several key questions linger
did attacker Salman Abadie receive help
making his bomb or more explosives
produced and are there plans for another
attack this ongoing investigation is now
the backdrop for a busy holiday weekend
with heightened security nationwide
athletes from around the world are in
town competing in the great city games
and Great Manchester run a half marathon
scheduled for tomorrow at its half the
job of the police is to protect the
public this weekend that's particularly
important whatever events you're going
to whether you're going shopping or
you're going to sporting events or music
events whatever this weekend I think
coach the public to carry on and it is a
sentiment that has also been echoed by
singer ariana grande who just announced
that she will return to Manchester to
perform that concert which does not have
a date just yet well
benefit all of the victims in this
attack in that statement announcing this
concert ariana grande said that this
city has been incredibly brave Anthony
Jonathan Vigliotti in Manchester England
Thank You Jonathan